[Music]
all right earlier this morning friends
of this program Charlie Kirk and Candace
Owens were brutally harassed by far-left
protesters they were having breakfast at
a Philadelphia coffee shop what's this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is now turning-point USA found a charlie
Kirk turning point us a communications
director Candace Owens both friends of
the show Pam Bondi secretary Neilson
Sarah Sanders Melania Trump Ivanka Trump
a 12 year old kid Barron Trump a 4 year
old granddaughter Chloe Trump this is
you know the media talks about them
because they say you suck and there
weren't this was you actually got
physically assaulted correct yeah water
thrown myself
they threw an egg at me and here's the
interesting part Candace and I were just
minding our own business we were just
having you know quiet breakfast and they
mobilized within 20 or 30 minutes at
least 50 of them came into the
restaurant started calling Candace a
Nazi which I can't quite figure out how
on earth they would come to that racial
comments made - right absolutely not
just to me they also to the police
officers this was a primarily black
police force is Philadelphia
there was only one white police officer
the rest were black and Hispanic they
called us race trainers they were saying
f the police and they were saying that
all police are racists despite the fact
that this was an all-white group and
Tifa facing an all-black police force
and myself telling us essentially that
we had to notice that you both kept your
cool and you stayed out you were not
gonna go back in I would probably if I
was there I would have stayed out
because I'm a lunatic but I would have
advised you guys to go inside well so
but you felt it was important well they
drove us out of the restaurant and
Candace and I said you know what let's
just stand here for a couple minutes and
and show them that we're not gonna back
down very peacefully when I can
retaliate if things get thrown at us
little did we know we actually have
stuff thrown at us but look we don't
want to play the victim card here that's
what the left does all the time instead
victim court but this is yes a warning
this is what's called on by Maxine
Waters this is our first get in their
face get in their face in grocery stores
in the mall if I remember correctly
restaurant she restaurants yeah so this
is Maxine Waters America and we felt it
was an important moment to show America
exactly what we are fighting because not
many people understand this is real they
have grown increasingly
violence because they understand that
they are losing they're losing a lot of
turf is this when I first met you I did
say what Charlie said as he thinks he
discovered you you didn't discover she
was a star under me I did say I saw a
great future for both of you to be fair
hasn't been as there been a lot of this
when they're expecting us yes if we're
on campuses of course if we're going to
give us a talk anywhere of course but
this was unusual because we weren't at a
trump rally we weren't on a campus we
were simply having coffee in a coffee
shop so sad yeah you know I'm Sarah
Sanders kids so one out of a restaurant
you know I don't talk about it I know
the left
I was said last week I'd be the first to
jump in if I'm at an event and anybody
put laid a hand on even Jim Acosta I
would joke I trained an hour and a half
a day mixed martial arts I fight and
it's real fighting and I would defend
anybody against physical but but it's
not the same of you using words here
they actually chased you out of the
restaurant and you were physically
really assaulted that that's correct and
we made the decision not to press
charges because look we're not going to
try to do what the left would do and try
to create martyrs so on and so forth
instead but we want to do is focus on as
a warning sign to the American people
that if the Democrats take that Congress
you're going to be electing these
radicals those are the vehicles are one
of many each the president's current
open borders eliminate eyes keep Obama
care they want their crumbs back and
they want these investigations to stop
that's exactly right and they had a
bullhorn and they were very close to my
face screaming in my ear
it was reminiscence of the civil rights
era this is what you would expect at the
civil rights era the black woman was
dining at a restaurant you know you
you've been through a lot though this is
not the first time it seems that race
comes up a lot because you happen to be
conservative and you happen to be an
african-american that's correct this is
every Dineen barelli's book member I
mentioned it to you
you know read that who will my name and
the most terrific names come up that's
correct
liberals believe that they own blacks so
they believe that there is something
proprietary about being black in this
country and if you deviate from the way
that they want you to think in a way
that they want you to act they grow
violent
it's changing did you see the Paul
Rasmussen I did you had predicted this
to me I did I said there's going to be a
major black exit from a Democratic Party
because we're starting to figure it out
when looking at the history which
they've wiped and we are realizing that
the Democratic Party was always racist
record low unemployment
african-americans Hispanic Americans
Asian Americans 14 states that's good
for our fellow citizens and you know
what all Americans it ought to be what
happened in Chicago just to dovetail if
we don't declare this a national
emergency that literally our American
family is being gunned down in the
streets and nobody's doing anything to
help our national treasure because
they're not illegal aliens if these were
illegal alien children that were gunned
down illegal alien children that were
separated because they lost their father
the outrage over that but you know what
nobody wants separation children and
Donald Trump fix that correct
but 71 people shot in a weekend with the
strictest gun laws in America no
celebrities came out talking about this
whatsoever and it's because these were
Americans you both are very brave and
courageous thank you both for being here